hey let's take a break from all of the
politics for a moment let's do something
completely different okay I got an email
from Chris Chris with a K by the way
which we're gonna put up on the screen
and Chris said hey David I know you
aren't a self-help guy but you seem to
have some good habits can you list the
easiest and simplest ways to improve
health and well-being that you've come
across well listen Chris is 100 right I
am not a self-help guy I'm not going to
be here to tell you about lobsters
cleaning their room or whatever it is
that Jordan Peterson is going to advise
you I I will give you what I think are
just some really low hanging fruit that
most people can do that in my experience
will put you you know there's this kind
of 80 20 rule right there's people out
there looking for the exact supplements
and what's the right number of reps to
squeeze into a 4 14-minute workout for
maximum gain and then what about uh uh
you you know taking apple cider vinegar
with lemon and and uh you know bathing
in blue light or not blue light in order
to sleep right there you can try to get
to 99 percent
but very often 80 20 is where you want
to be and there are some really simple
things that will get you like 80 percent
of the benefit of a lot of this stuff so
this is just my opinion I'm not a
self-help guy but here's just like a few
things that I would say first of all
walk 8 000 steps a day if you can make
it 10 000 even better okay you don't
know how much you're walking most phones
have a step tracker in them I use a
Fitbit that goes on my wrist if you're
walking 8 000 steps a day every day that
is already going to put you in terms of
mobility and and avoiding sort of like a
sedentary situation it's going to put
you ahead of 80 of people
if I look down if it's six o'clock or
seven o'clock and I look down and I've
only walked five or six thousand steps I
will just exit my house if I have to do
it after dinner when the baby's sleeping
and just walk for 15 minutes to get to
my 8 000 steps I will do it and I've
been doing this for years that alone is
going to give you this eighty percent
benefit with something that's super
simple okay in terms of diet
people will go and they'll say oh I need
what's the right type of oil now there's
this whole anti-seed oil thing that's
going on but it's already been debunked
and what about what what about keto and
all this all the okay
for me the simplest shorthand to eating
what is probably a pretty good diet
is to focus on getting 30 30 grams of
fiber in your diet per day how is this
possible how could that do so much I
think here's the reason why foods that
are high in fiber number one tend to be
less processed number two they tend to
be lower in saturated fat although some
of them have high good fats if you are
prioritizing 30 grams of fiber per day
you're probably eating a relatively
healthy diet just because of the foods
that have fiber okay so I know that
there's a million diets and then people
are finding a diet that's completely
unsustainable this that the other thing
oh you know now I'm on blueberries no
now I'm on acai or okay if you focus on
just trying to get 30 grams of fiber per
day you are already going to be ahead of
80 percent of the American population
number three drink enough water I find
sometimes at five o'clock I am not
feeling well and I'll think oh my
goodness is it the virus what is
happening here and then I'll realize I
went to the gym at two I then had a
meeting at a cafe where I had a coffee
and no water I haven't had water since
lunch and I worked out and it's 5 30. I
will have a glass of water and I will
feel better very quickly drink enough
water I wake up in the morning you know
how you bring that glass of water to
your nightstand and then you never drink
it the goal for me is I wake up and I
have it in the morning so drinking
enough water very very important protect
your sleep schedule at least five nights
a week okay and by that I mean if you
know how much sleep you need to feel
pretty good make sure that your schedule
allows you that sleeping schedule at
least five nights a week I try to go
with at least six nights a week if you
need 7 hours and 45 minutes
then you got to figure out how to get
there how do you eek out enough time to
be in bed and able to sleep that amount
of time and then lastly read every day
what's the deal with this reading what
what am I talking about I'm talking
about reading physical books fiction or
non-fiction whatever you want I read
nonfiction during the day fiction at
night if you are reading some number of
pages every single day and it's useful
stuff good fiction or useful non-fiction
you are going to be learning so much
more than the average person who's
reading no books no books at all I used
to have a a sort of like a minimum I
wanted to read 25 non-fiction Pages a
day and then some fiction at night
before going to bed I've recently upped
it to 30 pages a day of nonfiction if
I'm reading 80 books a year or whatever
it ends up working out to be and someone
else is reading zero that's an insane
leg up whether I'm interviewing for a
job or just for personal Enlightenment
and knowledge or being an interesting
person with things to talk about if I'm
reading 80 books and you aren't reading
any
that's going to create a big big gap in
enjoyment in knowledge and all of these
different things that's that's my list
and again I'm not a self-help guy is
there anything magical about 8 000 steps
I I don't know is there anything magical
about 30 grams of fiber I think that's
what's recommended maybe for men and for
women it's a little bit less I don't
think any of these things are magic but
they're just the things I've found that
are really useful to me and almost
anyone can do them with relatively
little struggle let me know your
thoughts that's probably the only
self-help type segment we're going to
get on the show for a while